you're a big snapchat fan well yeah I
know that and when I know about
someone's snapchat account to really
know what's hit the ceiling because I'm
an old-timer see yeah yeah you've got
you're very funny on snapchat well yeah
well I actually I smack chats filters
and just put them on Instagram only cuz
I'm lazy and don't want to build a whole
whole new set of followers but yeah I
like Zak actually said it he put it best
he's like you like those little filters
because it finally puts a strange weird
face to all the strange weird voices you
do and I'm like yeah that's that's
probably right you spend a lot of time
doing this stuff I like it I like to
make it dark and weird and silly you
also make up songs yes you made a song
that's it been in my head for a while
about pizza yeah I have I mean and and
bizarrely I have a lot of parents
sending me clips of their kids singing
that song and what's the weirdest thing
is like my DM thread my direct message
to my scram is a lot of videos of kids
and a lot of them are in the bathtub and
I don't know what to do if only they
knew they were sending it to someone who
I love it that's how you won the crowd
over lots of videos of kids in the
bathroom here I was thinking I'm the
weird one
yeah they were just waiting for you to
get to that part the part we can all
relate you know we have a we have so I
think some of your snapchats right here
with a lot of great and just kept you
hanging out with all your dad dogs all
the kids that are coming around here
putting sand in my pool it cost me about
$600 for
you did it
I'm waiting for mother up here with your
dead dogs
yeah um beanie I'll take the followers
yeah yeah Graham
you